I told myself going into the locker room
Melanie when you had breasts you would
not have been modest you would not be
covering yourself up to any greater
degree so this is what you will do now
when the doctor told me I'm sorry to say
you have breast cancer I just went blank
I was diagnosed needing a single
mastectomy of my right breast I knew
from the start that I wasn't interested
in reconstruction symmetry is important
to me as an individual
it's my breasts or nothing
shopping for that bathing suit that was
hard you know I have 17 inches of scar
on my chest my skin doesn't move the way
it used to and it needs stretching doing
it in the water just feels better than
anything else anywhere else
when I made this decision I told myself
just embrace this
be it be all of it I've posed for a few
different projects the grace project I
posed for play out underwear these
projects they're great for me there's an
aspect of being able to see myself
I'm not defined by my breasts or my lack
of breasts visual representation for
this body type is very important so that
no women feel like they need to hide